Actress Michelle Yeoh
is no fan of glass ceilings.
Neither her age nor her nationality,
nor her gender can stop her
from taking Hollywood by storm
Fresh off a Golden Globe award
for her virtuoso performance
in Everything, Everywhere All At Once,
Yellow leads
the list of contenders for this year's
best actress Oscar.
Her star
vehicle is an idiosyncratic movie
about a Chinese laundromat owner
thrust into a mission
to save all possible universes.
So no pressure there.
Take a look at this clip
from the trailer.
He's waiting in the wings.
The universe
he speaks of senseless
things is so much bigger
than you realize.
From all the places
I could be
I just want to pursue this.
You
remember our mission
transcending the fate
of every single will
of our infinite multiverse.
There is no way I am the Evelyn
you are looking for.
And Michelle Yeoh is with me here.
Welcome to the program.
Thank you so much.
I'm so happy to be here.
Well, it is amazing.
And you've got so many accolades
for this remarkable role.
What I just literally can't believe
and I wonder how you feel about
it is the first Hollywood movie
where you have had top billing in a long
and distinguished career.
When you saw the script
and you saw your role,
what did you think?
First of all, I prayed and say, please
let these two boys
not be certifiably insane, okay?
The two boys are the Daniels who wrote
this is the original screenplay.
It's come from Daniel
Kwan and Daniel Shine.
And when I received it, you know,
it's like you received scripts and as
the years get
bigger, the numbers get bigger.
The roles seem to shrink
with that, right.
As you know, as a woman,
as an aging woman or whatever it is,
somehow they start putting you in boxes.
And it's always
the guy who gets to go on the adventure
and save the world
and, you know, rescue your daughter.
And you think, why can't I do that, too?
So it was so overwhelming
at that point to get a script
that said you know,
this is a very ordinary woman, an Asian
immigrant woman
who's dealing with all the problems
that we all can relate to while
maybe not as a laundromat owner, but,
you know, the relationship
with your husband, relationship
with your father, relationship
with your daughter
I mean, that's the generational gap
that miscommunication between
mothers and daughters especially.
It's always been more complicated.
And what I loved about it, it was like
this is an ordinary woman
who is being seen,
who is given a role
to play as a superhero.
And that's what we are
women mothers, daughters,
sisters are superheroes
because we have a certain superpower,
which is kindness, love, compassion
and the core of this crazy, wacky, messy,
you know, frenetic story on the surface.
The core is authentic, genuine, love,
full family
and never giving up on each other.
I am going to play a clip
where you don't look for love
and compassion. Who are you?
Very, very out.
Let's say this.
Let's play this clip from
Go
Oh, look,
ow, ow, ow,
ow, ow.
Look
what happened.
I think they lost their powers
So in this, a madcap sci
fi and multi genre film, at least
you would want to list the genres,
because it is it is crazy.
It is.
Sci fi is horror,
it's romance, it's drama, it's comedy.
It's like
maybe I've been in rehearsing
for 40 years for this ultimate role.
It is just amazing to be able to have
the opportunity to say, I can do this.
Please let me show you.
And you have done
what is the compassionate mother that
she was doing acting.
Her daughter and the husband
because these
I don't know what you call them,
the agents have come
from another universe
and they are trying to destroy
each universe system magically.
So what we have to do is to try it.
I have to do
is to protect my universe, my family.
And this is backwards.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And this is the multi universe thing
that is, you know, is the.
It's amazing
because what
the Daniels have done is like,
you know, how we look at our lives
and we look
and we say,
I wish I had done it differently.
Perhaps the outcome
would have been better.
And you know how
especially immigrant parents
have a tendency to say to their children,
I left a good life for you
so you can have a better life?
I could have done things differently,
but for you.
So sometimes it's
that miscommunication into feeling.
And then the younger ones go like,
you don't have to do things for me.
I could do it for myself.
So I see what this movie,
when it came out, it appealed.
It resonated with different generations.
It was like shining a light on them
to say
sometimes we just have to step back.
The motivation is really from love
is from care.
And what I really love is
sometimes people walk up to the streets
and say,
I'm about my age and say,
I didn't really get your movie
because, you know,
it gets a little crazy for me.
But I was confused, too.
Yeah,
but my estranged young daughter
that I have not spoken to in the movie.
No, no.
In real life
came to the mother and say,
I've watched this movie.
And I think I understand
what you are trying to do for me.
So it's healed certain relationships,
it's opened up conversations,
and I think that's what we need to do.
Is have conversations
because the last few years
have been so difficult on so many levels.
Right?
With the pandemic, with with things
with tragedies and things like that,
it was nice to have a movie
where it's like
embraced here.
How does it
how does some of this play into
or play off your own experience?
You also are an immigrant,
you know, from Malaysia.
But nonetheless,
you left in order to have a better life.
You came from a very, you know,
I guess, upper middle class family.
The father was a lawyer.
How does that
does any part of your experience resonate
with the film character?
It resonated tremendously.
I think what it resonated with
was the relationship
you know, with the older generation
understanding.
I have,
unfortunately, you know,
too many conversations.
Luckily, not from my parents,
where my father was very forward
thinking, was never,
never told any of us
that, you know, daughters were
next behind the son.
So in that way,
he empowered me to believe
that, you know,
if you believe you can do
it, you should go for it.
And that was how it always has been
with myself, my career in that way.
So I felt it was very important
to shine
the light of someone
who didn't have that kind of privilege,
who didn't have that kind of support.
Like Evelyn Wong her father.
That's you in the film.
That's me in the film.
Literally just said to you
your complete failure rate.
I tell you not to go off with this man.
Look where you end up
in a failing laundromat.
Bad business with a daughter
that looks like a mess.
But I think at the end of the day,
it was like I remember,
I think
at that time
when my dad said to me,
I wish you enough, I didn't quite get it.
But I think with this movie,
what resonated was
she told her daughter,
it doesn't matter what you are,
how you think.
You're not living up to my expectations.
You are enough.
You and just about everybody
to do with this film
have been nominated in
in all your categories.
I was just staggered to read
that actually, Jackie Chan
might have been chosen for the lead
role, that it might have gone to a man
and somebody much older than you.
Obviously, it was written for man.
When Daniel
set out to do this, you know,
I think whenever filmmakers
tell the story,
they also have to be mindful
it is show business.
I have to write something
that somebody will make it into a film
and so they wrote it
like that way with Jackie
and me as the wife.
So it was completely
the role was reversed.
Yeah.
And I remember
Jackie texted me
and said, congratulations.
You know,
you realize
that your boys came to see me first,
and I'm like, Thank you, bro.
I mean, seriously, a huge favor.
Yeah.
So did you turn it down
or did the Daniels decide that?
I think it was
it was it was mutual because, you know,
Jackie is very, very busy.
And, you know,
he's got so many things going on.
And I think
Daniels also stepped back and said,
then we're doing something
that's already been done before
why we should do it differently.
And they both have very strong women
in their lives, whether it's the mothers
or the the wife and the partners.
So they are very inspired
and they're not afraid of strong women.
I think that is the most beautiful thing
about these boys, just like
they celebrate strong woman.